it's great to be here thanks everyone
for coming to the early slot in the
morning I know it's an effort to a
certain extent so thanks for coming here
this is I guess the first session on
adversary adversarial robustness or the
first talk on this day of adversarial
robustness and robustness talk I'm gonna
talk I'll give a brief introduction
because that's the role of the first
person I think in the day but then I'll
talk largely about some reasonable work
we've been doing on the provable
robustness via a technique called
randomized smoothing we have a lot of
sort of work kind of broadly this area
I'll touch on some of that including
some older work by Eric long but the
majority this talk is going to focus on
some work by Jeremy in the line on on
using these randomized methods and
smoothing methods to get guarantees
about robustness okay so so since this
is the first talk of the day on
robustness is my maybe unfortunate duty
to have to actually walk through the
slides that you've all seen before on
robustness or hopefully many of you seen
before robustness and they cause the big
question of this is do you start with
Ian's picture of the Panda or the Alex's
picture of the of the pig and given the
Alex was in fact the organizers event
you know I certainly went you know
honored him and use the use the Flying
Pig as our example so the idea here is
I'm sure many of you know deep
classifiers as Jason had in his you know
brief interaction yesterday or solving
the whole world's problems but they had
this big issue and the big issue will a
many big issues but one big issue is
that you can take classifiers that
simply work perfectly well you add a
little tiny bit of imperceptible noise
carefully chosen and you can basically
make them predict anything you want them
protected they can be arbitrarily fool
and the idea of course is very simple
here and these things are all
differentiable so just like you can
differentiate to maximize parameters you
can also differentiate the inputs of
these things define to basically
maximize the loss or maximize the
targeted loss maybe that you know try to
classify something else and this idea
has received a lot of prominence in
recent years I think the recent surge of
interest is largely due to some work out
of Google and and others but to be clear
this this sort of idea of robustness of
classifiers goes back well well beyond
this politically the contents of
adversarial ml goes back at least 15
years but of course even more so this is
related to issues of just SVM's and
margins as well as robust optimization
so I really don't want to even quantify
when this started but I will say that in
2012 2015 it was sort of appreciated
these problems were very very prevalent
specifically for deep networks and I
think they are actually quite the issues
do become more pronounced and deep
networks and so because of that these
issues have received a lot more
attention this issue of robustness here
now before I jump into kind of what we
can do about this I do want to try to at
least answer a little bit of this
question which I get a lot about why
should we care about this right I mean
there's a totally fair question because
till this example I mean this is a
something's go back here this is a very
carefully crafted noise here it was
specifically chosen to maximize the loss
knowing the models gradients those kind
of things and in that case you know is
this really indicative ISM we're ever
going to encounter in the world we're
probably not and so you know if you
actually have an adversary controlling
the pixel inputs to your system able to
manipulate them you know in a in a
bitwise fashion you probably have bigger
problems than then you know
misclassifying you're a pig as an
airplane but there are I think there are
and I think there despite this fact
there are really a lot of very good
reasons to still care about this very
much so and they're really two that I
typically highlight here when I when I
when I think about motivating this area
of research the first one is there
really are I believe and I think
probably Nicolas what we'll touch in
this a little bit more as well or maybe
he will there really are genuine
security implications
for these things so we are starting to
trust to entrust AI systems to make
predictions that have real consequences
and when you do this you want some
notion of you know some hope they will
work beyond just the exact data that
they were trained upon and if they're in
high critical you know in sort of
mission-critical scenarios like
self-driving cars or health decisions
the fact that attackers can actually
fool these things does seem to be
problematic and this is not just I mean
though there's examples I'm showing
there are kind of these digital
artifacts these are not just digital
phenomena so people have shown you can
basically do the same thing in the real
world so here's a colleague of mine at
CMU putting on glasses with a little
funny pattern on them to make a face
detection system think he is this person
who he is not some work out of Berkeley
I don't know if any of them are here but
some some were kind of Don song's group
show that you can put stickers on stop
signs to make classifiers classify these
as speed limit signs instead some work
out of MIT the 3d printed a turtle that
was supposed to look like a rifle from
any angles this this pattern of markings
and the turtle makes things the rifle
this is kind of hard to see here but we
did some work recently showing you can
actually replace a patched kind of
anywhere in the image to suppress all
object detection that happens anywhere
else in that image it's not just that is
the onion overlapping what you've sort
of changed but anywhere else in the
image this computer is cups and suffer
normally detected but with this patch
here they're all they all vanish and I
think you know as we think about
deploying ml to security critical
scenarios we need to understand the
risks involved just like we need to
understand computer security risks when
we deploy you know large scale computer
security problems and so I think this is
not something to ignore here there
really are security implications here
but in addition and I think probably as
as Alex will will highlight even more I
also think this says something very
fundamental about the nature of our
classifiers so the fact that these
things exist tells us something I think
fundamental about what these classifiers
are learning the fact that they seem to
be learning things that are very
different from the representations that
we think about using when we want to
classify objects
about the smoothness of the decision
boundaries that there that are being
implied here and about sensitivity as
you know related to what Ben was talking
about yesterday of things like
sensitivity to distribution shift so in
some sense the adversarial setting is
you know capturing the worst case
distribution shift within that allowable
threat model right so within the threat
model of basically allowing
perturbations over some of our some
region Delta okay so that's adversarial
attacks on networks and now I want to
talk about adverse LOL robustness to to
to these attacks so if we want to
actually make a system that will not
classify this as an airliner but in fact
classify as a pig what do we do and the
basic idea here is actually quite simple
or what what well what we should do is
quite simple you can do other things but
you shouldn't do which which may be
Nicolas will also talk about but what
you do is you just rethink your normal
loss function so normally we put a
parameters in our network to minimize
the expected value of losses of our
network you know under those parameters
and since now what we're concerned about
is not just this sort of no nominal
osip's I actually added a delta path
should not the good Delta there I guess
I'm not doing anything with passive
Delta equals zero in that case but what
we're switching to as you might know
this sort of alludes to is this other
setting where now because we cared about
the setting where you maximize over some
perturbation that you add to your image
we actually now want to just in this you
know in the most natural setting we went
um instead find network parameters that
for the worst-case perturbation still
minimized this sort of worst-case loss
this is classical robust optimization to
be clear but applying it in this ml
profession the deep learning context
there's a little bit it's a little bit
interesting so this is the optimization
problem associated with adversarial
robustness and there really are two ways
I think you can go about doing this okay
there is a third way which is you just
try to do something that might work in
some cases but when you do that then
again Nicolas writes a paper a few weeks
later
about how your thing doesn't work so if
he wants us to actually work you should
really do one of two things the first
thing you can do is it goes by the name
adversarial training it's very simple
we're gonna take normal STD steps on our
models we're gonna use normal STD in our
model but we're not going to take steps
yeah question is why is the actual label
of our example X yes if you perturb by
Delta yeah your label changes but that's
also the correct label yeah okay okay
that's a good point so if you make such
a big perturbation this actually becomes
an airplane instead of a yeah so the key
element here is this perturbation region
Delta and really in all the work we do
we are assuming perturbation regions
Delta that are small enough such that we
assume that any perturbation in this
region should not change the label now
coming up with that perturbation region
is a whole nother issue which I'm not
going to touch on when you know we
typically so really what you want there
is you want like semantic similarity
something a really confusing and hard
write what you can't get at so what we
do instead is we use really simple
heuristics like L infinity bounds like
really simple things that we know with a
small enough degree we can't even see
these things so we should definitely be
the same level so this in the normal
case is a necessary but not sufficient
condition for true robustness but the
fact is that we can't even do this yet I
think speaks to a very important aspect
of our current systems yeah minor
modification of the question is if these
was their regression setting yeah yeah
perhaps what you want is that he changes
in a small amount as well so really this
is a notion of
exactly so essentially this is absolute
Lipchitz notion so it's a notion about
the Lipsius constant of the underlying
classifier and so yes no progression
setting but you like you can for me this
two things all the same way whereas you
know essentially at the Lipschitz
constant you want to ensure that a
certain change your input does not
change your output but very much these
are all about smoothness which is why we
don't we're using smoothing to solve
these things okay so so add resort
training is this simple thing where you
just basically take a few steps but you
don't take them at the normal not the
nominal points you first kind of solve
this problem and then take an SVG step
at the worst case solution there now of
course it's hard to solve this problem
is that this is a non convex problem and
we can't do that instantly great job of
solving it but that's never really
bothered us before in deep learning the
fact that we can't solve problems so
what we do is we just try to sell this
approximately say via PGD or via some
any sort of attack you can come up with
I mean the inner problem is just finding
you know the attack vector and you take
steps at the worst case example and by
actually you know some simple table the
incidence theorem this sort of says that
this is actually you know the the the
gradient at the worst case thing is
actually the gradient of this Mac
subjected under pretty general
conditions so that's sort of the first
thing you can do the challenge there
though and by the way that does that
does work to a certain extent and this
is the basis for the best empirical
defenses that we know how to construct
but if we want to go beyond just sort of
saying something that works in practice
if one actually have guarantees about
the you know all the things definitely
secure in this entire region not just
the best we can do with some non
comeback solver we need some other way
and so this leads to what I would call
provable or certified defenses there was
a question about is there difference
between those terms no there's not I use
them interchangeably and so a certified
defense will actually do something like
form actual upper bound on this quantity
here and the upper bound this quantity
and show that you know the worst case
loss and this upper balance this
quantity
never say you know becomes for error
never becomes more than one then we've
actually or you know if you just look at
the function itself the function never
becomes
sort of say then then we can actually
guarantee here that this would actually
be sort of that not not just robust but
certifiably robust to any sort of
perturbation again within our set so if
we can again if we can compute this
upper bound here an upper bounds on this
inner quantity we can actually get
guarantees about the robustness of
classifiers and these are the two things
you really should do one of these two is
what you should do if you want to
develop a classifier that is robust
against adversarial attacks so just to
give a quick sense and and and so you
know a lot of our usual work sort of
look exactly at this kind of method of
upper bounding Zinner problem and to see
how we do that it's actually quite I
couldn't sort of I'm gonna describe it
in one slider and then maybe two slides
but focus actually mainly on another
approach in this talk and the basic idea
is we take our problem so we want to
maximize our function over Delta we're
gonna masu we're going to assume here
that the network is going to be a
feed-forward network with nothing but
rel u s-- as i know when they already we
can actually construct other things as
well but that's sort of a simple case
and we started out with just a rail u
case so what you can do if you have rail
use is the the only non-linearity the
only reason law has problems hard to
solve is because of the rail use right
those are the only non linearity
everything else is linear in the network
so what we do is we relax the Aurelia's
to the convex hull of their rail use
assuming some lower upper bounds which
themselves are hard to get but we get
them kind of narrative fashion but if
you have the lord upper bound
you can relax the rail you to be a
convex hull of the rail you and what's
cool now is that this maximization
problem now becomes actually a linear
program because our nonlinearities
miralax to these linear regions and our
other all the other terms of network are
linear so we get a nice sort of linear
program that does this that still sort
of hard to solve so we don't really
probably want to solve that so we showed
in some of our work because you can
actually very efficiently create a dual
of this problem and find a feasible dual
Ellucian very efficiently Bissell using
a single back prop pass which is not at
all obvious how you do that but we can
do that so you can construct a dual
relaxation of this of this a further
relaxation of this LP which actually
corresponds to relaxing this this thing
a little bit further into this poly tape
there and this is actually correspond
exactly to a dual of this LP though you
can also infinity derive this with
things like hybrids ona topes as a group
every th did or with forward Lipsius
constants as others did this is
essentially how these balance works by
optimizing over these things you
actually get a provable bound which is
easy to compute relatively so on on on
this thing and that's nice i think when
i when we first started doing this we
were really excited because this is you
know the first time we get actual
provable bounds on these things and we
could you know certify em this 2 percent
certified error we could you know start
working on start getting results on CFR
and unfortunately it seemed to kind of
break down yeah yeah so those are a good
question so depth scales badly with
scales okay but the reality is the
quality of how tight this outer bound
ends up being you really dependent on
how you train the network so if you
train the network to minimize the upper
bound as we do so we actually end up
training the network right to minimize
upper bound then the bound by that
procedure becomes fairly tight whereas
if you just take a normal network
normally train and evaluate the bound
it's always vacuous so-so but when you
train the network even for relatively
deep networks it can become out there
can become relatively tight now the
problem though there's a few problems
and the problem is that these bounds
ultimately however are just too loose
that's that that's the real problem here
even when you train on them for large
networks for large enough networks that
you really want to use for bigger
problems like even like CFR certainly
but see if our certainly image net
there's there's two problems they're
just too loose in other words minimizing
them over regularizes the
network to a point where it isn't very
good anymore and secondly they don't
very scalable so even with all these
trips of duality and everything they
still get still take you know a large
multiple of the time it takes a train a
normal network and it just doesn't seem
like there they're really going to scale
up the size of imagenet data's has to be
one of scale t I guess what makes them
loose with 610 is that it all at the
heart of all of them they're still about
kind of propagating a kind of interval
balance so you know you have to bound
the upper and lower regions of this rail
you if those become loose and they
become looser looser as you go deeper in
the network you're balancing just get
very loose because you have you actually
have too much sort of slack that you're
to allow in these over and in these
relaxations so and ashley you know
haughty and and jerry too had a paper
recently on on sort of the fact that all
of these previous approaches the
different a lot of them and want papers
on these things they're basically all
doing the exact same thing and they all
have this fundamental barrier that comes
down to this sort of interval balance
the convex relaxation it's this part
here just this this this you know slop
you have here that's just that's just
too much for big because imagine as
these these upper lower bounds get
bigger right then this becomes a very
big region you can cheat a lot and so
manipulating your your activations and
that and that's just to lose that one is
not doesn't seem to be as bad it is bad
but hadees work actually evaluate the
exact LP and you know what the exact LP
you can't do you can't these things just
they don't work that much better
especially to train them in the dual
they work kind of the same way so it's
like that there isn't very much
looseness in about yeah
so so again this is also an empirical
this isn't this isn't sort of the theory
but empirically they don't the
penetration the width because adding
with it adds more units but each the
upper and lower bounds you know only
start expanding a lot when you add depth
the network when these things combine so
just adding width doesn't seem to
effective that much so actually the
better networks here that we have are
wider but shallower networks for these
things so there's no if your depend on
with too much yeah we tried I mean yes
we can try all the different all the
different activations 10h so those don't
you know those saturate Sigma I mean
everything doesn't doesn't there's no
quick fix to these things oh yeah these
are guarantees right so this is an
actual upper bound on this quantity
saying no matter what you do if you are
attack within this region you are safe
it is a guarantee it's saying Vic
because it's an strict upper a strict
upper bound on this quantity no attack
within a certain perturbation region
you're defending against could ever ever
do it no matter of her papers Nicolas
and others published the first ever I
was confident enough to the published in
this area because I knew assuming our
math is right which I was pretty sure
about we couldn't we wouldn't be broken
two months later the fact that at least
for linear networks was real you you
eventually just get an affine map and
you need to divide the space into
regions so yeah the perturbations that
matter only if
you change the region yeah this actually
will be so if you have a case like this
where your where your perturbation keeps
you in a certain region you get exact
balance for free because you'll have
both the upper and lower things be on
the same side here and so you're sort of
you sort of get an exact bound you says
we the bound is exact in that case if
you stay within linear region this
allows you to get provable bounds when
you when you cross them your regions
despite that fact that you're crossing
them and so that's what sort of nice
error region because there is finitely
many even though it's a combinatorial
number why couldn't you just well yeah
it's a common total number that's why
you can't do it so that I mean to be
clear like this is an integer program
solving this problem exactly is an
integer program but we're talking an
inner program with a number of variables
equal the number of hidden units to the
network this is never it's not it's not
a matter of you know
a few more years as a matter of the
universe dying before it happens right
like this is this is not gonna be
scalable ip's at that level i don't
think unless unless you specify the
network to make the IP better to solve
which is actually alex has some actually
not yeah alex has the student working on
that as well it one more question
because this is not what this talk is
about and i'll move on yes
so so you know yeah but in the end you
are only going to move them nearby so
you can just go straight the number you
can move to within a perturbation region
of reasonable size is already way way
bigger than anything you would ever be
able to solve and practice the the IP
solvers do all that and the right branch
and bound way they already do all that
the the nice cutting but like the nice
cutting plants and a nice branch and
balance stuff they're already factoring
that in and you really can't do it
there's a huge number of these regions
that you have to you have to certify
over I think I might move on from this
so this is again not the topic of this
talk or I thought it wasn't only topic
of this talk maybe it was okay so so
looks like well this talk is about now
okay where the talk is about is about a
kind of different approach to this
because we really feel like we've hit a
limit or I think we've hit a limit is
with current approaches that are just
based on these two Valatie bounds and
what I want to talk about a point like
what said is a different approach based
upon really a much simpler methods in
them all that way is there that there
the math actually quite a bit simpler
that do end up scaling to much larger
data set sizes and they're really the
only approach I mean our our work but
also the other other work in this area
is actually really the only approach
that scales and things like like
imagenet discuss scale data sets so let
me say let me jump into what I mean by
randomized smoothing here and how this
actually helps and I will sort of go
through the proof of this intuitive and
intuitive manner of how this helps with
robustness so before I do let me talk
about what causes adverse my do these
things exist I personal examples again
in the cartoon way so they exist because
I mean if we think that our customers
work well kind of on average or the
tilly they work well and there's a
random noise but they don't work well
under adversarial noise what that means
is you have your classifier here and you
know say this is the point you want to
input and this is the the correct class
system in current class what what it
means that this is the adversarial
example means that there is some maybe
small you know small measure region of
the wrong class kind of jutting into
you really close by our target point and
I mean to be clear it doesn't like this
because what it really means is that
every point has one of these I mean this
is hiding the pie dimension alright so
every point in space you really classify
has these nearby points jutting into it
there's some other class and you just if
you just want to search that other other
point you can find it without too much
work
and so this sort of motivates a very
natural defensive strategy so to avoid
this we just say let's just smooth our
our predictions I mean this was trying
to before this is all about Lipsius
constants right shutting things that jut
in mean you have a high Lipsius constant
means you're really confident here and
not very common like really confident
the other way here that means your
boundary is just you know your system
functions are extremely crazy and so
let's just smooth them to avoid this so
I'm picking it let's go convolve with a
gaussian let's just add Gaussian noise
to our input
I picked the majority class over you
know over the the draws of Gaussian
noise so to be a little clearer here
what I'm saying is this is our F in all
cases will refer to the underlying
classifier I'll drop Veda cuz much I'm
not gonna worry about the parameters too
much of our model anymore
every day it's gonna refer to our
underlying base classifier and G is
gonna refer to the classifier that just
samples noise from a Gaussian and
computes the majority class of the
classifier under this couch in
perturbation so it's really simple but
to be clear it's doing it's it's I'm
assuming for now both these things
actually output classes not necessarily
the decision function there's the class
predictions just to keep it simple so
this is you know it outputs no negative
1 or positive 1 or 0 or 1 and then this
predicts you know 0 or 1 this one which
is the most likely class output by the
by the Bayes classifier
under Gaussian noise and to be very
clear you know this is not a new
approach then I have a new approach in
this context this actually was already
proposed as many times I should say as a
heuristic defense because it's very
natural right if things are too spiky
he's smooth them out a little bit so as
proposed many times as a heuristic
defense but then it was also been
proposed before and analyzed I should be
clearly clear as a certified defense so
the real work start
here with listen work by the quarry at
all and later some work quietly at all
and they actually to demonstrate that
this gives this procedure can give
certified results now what our work does
is it simplifies the analysis and also
effect so it proves a better bound and
in fact we also show that bound is tight
and that actually that is actually you
cannot do any better
so it's an exact characterization of how
well you can do under this couch and
smoothing procedure if you make no more
assumptions on your classifier it's
going to be an l2 bound
yes which all which I'll come to in a
few sense but yes we're going to talk
only about the case I'll mention at the
end it's very hard to send to other
cases we're gonna talk about
perturbations that lie with an l2 ball
of the original point yeah
yes yeah so what if you like use like
the Bayes classifier instead of just
think so so I said you can get similar
guarantees of you know on log loss and
stuff like this but we're just for this
kind of is where it's gonna analyze
error as we're guarantees on the air
yeah we haven't analyzed it too much
that but I suspect it wouldn't be too
hard to show if you don't look at just a
maximum class but I should look at the
actual probabilities here can you get a
certified bound on the log loss the
answer is we haven't done it but I'm
pretty sure you can yeah it's just sort
of see what this looks like now visually
and in a different way
the basic idea I mean I think everyone
can get to this point if you want to
classify this thing you don't bother
classifying that instead you sample a
bunch of random perturbations of
Gaussian noise applied to this thing you
classify all these images here and you
take the majority vote to over all of
them that's a procedure for smoothing
these things now one thing it's
important to note which I may come back
to later but maybe not is that this does
require that our base classifier be able
to classify noisy images right because
we're applying discovered to this there
is no guarantee that a classifier you
train on normal images will have to be
able to do that task so we end up
training our classifier on these noisy
images to try to classify them and that
seems to work though other people and I
think Jerry is maybe one of them team
working are working on other ways of
training it that actually work a little
bit better so there are there are other
ways you can train we're just going to
train on these noisy images that's a
great point and we don't do that you can
see what we're doing is sort of a simple
it's sort of like that like the simple
you know one sample multicolored
approximation to that but with like you
know
Jennsen equality applied to like one to
one exhibit but yeah you're right
you want to train the actual smooth
classifier and we aren't doing that yet
though Jerry we'll get at that more I
think or he is doing something that's
more like that yes
choices that would sort of automatically
make you so making our kitchens I think
it's a great question
can what is better about architectures
it's nothing really considering I think
for the most the most part there has
been some work in this like there's new
things like local activation functions
seem to be better than these values but
but we don't really deal with that we're
trying to use normal architectures like
res nuts and see how well they work yeah
between from scratch here but you could
transfer possibly to we just returned
from scratch
okay so if you do this maybe maybe move
along one of these these are the theorem
and the proof if you do this here's the
guarantee you get it's a really simple
guarantee so given some input X I'm
gonna let Y hat be the prediction of the
smooth classifier it's not not the
underlined after that the smooth
classifier I'm gonna let P which has the
greater than one-half so it's gonna be
the binary case we're gonna talk about
so just two classes and we'll let P
which is he's gonna be the probability
of that class under the distribution so
it has to be greater than one-half
because otherwise they wouldn't have
picked everybody pick the other class so
so again Y hat is the is the prediction
and P is the probability that the smooth
class that that when you add the random
noise you know what fraction of samples
were classified that way you know under
our noise what fraction of samples were
actually classified as as this Y hat
pasty more than one half so here's our
given this here's our guarantee then
what we can guarantee is the prediction
of the smooth classifier with a
perturbation added will also be equal to
the same thing in other words the
classifier is robust to perturbations
Delta where they're l2 norm of Delta is
less than this quantity is less than the
variance the standard deviation of our
of our sample of our sample the
tribution
times the Gaussian inverse CDF applied
to the probability yesterday and that's
that's the guarantee nice to sort of get
some intuition what this looks like what
this means is if I add more noise I can
certify a bigger radius but of course
the more nose I add the heart of the
task gets to classify these things so
there's a trade-off there and then the
higher the probability is this thing
also increases so if I if I do this
sampling and get you know 99.9% of all
my samples our are in fact the the same
class as Y hat I'll have a growth will
be hidebound
if only about 50% are I'll have you with
the below bound in fact the Gaussian CDF
looks like the gotta see it looks like
this so at
if I only get half then I am basically
guessing anyway so I can't do anything
so I my radius is zero and as I get more
and more confident my radius grows to it
to infinity back to Big Brother infinity
because the Gaussian has has full
support so the only way to get you know
true actual hundred percent probability
as if everywhere you classify is
positive which is the triple classifier
but that would give you an infinite
radius but of course you never get that
right and you can't actually also
certify that with Monte Carlo sampling
which we'll get to later we won't worry
about that for now so again this is the
bound makes sense it doesn't let me let
me answer any question of that now this
is the radius under which the prediction
of our smooth classifier will not change
anything which is totally weird right
cuz before we put all this effort in
analyzing the exact form of this of this
network and that's the thing is that
this is the biggest gap which I'll get
to at the very end right now yeah well
it spends on facility because the are
casual will affect what this probability
is and how well you do on it I mean the
better architectures get better
performance of course right so that's
how it implies that that's how it
affects it but there's no I mean there's
no dependence here on the actual
architecture in the form of the bounds
of self so this is not a generalization
performance this is just about actual
smoothing of the classifier I'm not
talking about generalization at all here
that's hard enough in a different
setting right talk about channelization
for deep learning I'm just talking about
the smooth classifier in terms of its
predictions right so you can verify a
test set by just looking at the test set
and knowing the true labels and seeing
or you can verify your prediction that
it won't change right but yes this is
not any sort of generalization guarantee
this is just saying that functionally my
smooth classifier will not change labels
question is this Delta is a function of
X right it's all function of X only in
so far is that what X is will affect the
probability of correct classification
and that will affect the radius you can
certify yes yes yeah I mean cuz you
there is points on the boundary yeah
right there the ratio is decision
boundary here if you hit it you can't
certify so yes of course the the radius
here so here to you your your certified
for will depend on their point your
according the only differently is that
is it's actually this one is not any
different
the only difference comes in the fact
that you can't compute this probability
exactly because this is an exact
composition of the Gaussian so I'm
practicing it to have a high probability
guarantees instead of deterministic ones
but really those are very high
probability says it's not that different
it's pretty similar okay so let me let
me prove this this back now and that'll
probably bring me to the end of my time
so I think before I prove it actually I
want to sort of frame it in terms of a
very reasonable question which is we got
a lot and we started talking does it fit
first which is look adversarial noise is
worst case it's measure zero
it was trained on the model how on earth
can performance on random noise tell
which which is not adversarial tell you
anything about performance in the worst
case totally fair question I think so I
want to go through sort of the intuition
of the proof you know and hopefully a an
intuitive but informal manner because
it's a really simple idea actually and
the way I'm gonna do is I'm gonna set up
this this kind of game and I'm gonna
suppose that I have two points X and X
plus Delta and on because our
classifiers are arbitrary here the
underline classifier f is arbitrary
we're gonna let an adversary choose
whatever F they wants they can be a
presenting kind of craft the underlines
this boundary however they want to craft
it to maximally kind of trick the smooth
classifier right again we're coming with
the bound for the smooth classifier so
we're gonna let the adversary kind of
manipulate the
underlying classifier as much as it
wants to such that two things have to
happen basically X has to be classified
one leg and X plus Delta has to be
classified a different way so if the
adversary can construct some underlying
measure such that that happens then this
classifier is not robust to this
perturbation the smooth classifier is
not robust to the perturbation so how
would you go about doing this how would
you go about constructing some
underlying prediction to fool the smooth
classifier let me talk about how you
might do that here it's a few a few you
know points in space here and here I'm
going to understand I'm going to draw
the underlying classifier and this one
I'm going to draw the smooth version of
that so one thing you might want to do
if you're if you're playing this game as
an adversary is you might want to put
you know high you know this example here
has the blue class and this example here
has the has the the green the orange
class this is a normal adversarial
example for this classifier F but as I
saw before what happens when you smooth
this now is that the smooth version in
the smooth version you will kind of
smooth out these bumps because the
majority class in this region here is
still the blue class even though this
center point is the is the orange one
what that means is essentially and I'll
hopefully if this is sort of confusing
wait wait wait for the punchline
hopefully that part will make sense this
is this doesn't work in the case of
smooth classifiers this this is an
average of example for the underlying
base classifier does not translate to
the smooth classifier get to the
opposite two right you can also do
something like this where you know maybe
you put most of your mass on the orange
class and their little mass on the blue
class around this example but this has
the same problems before right the
smooth classifier
well again actually classify these two
things it's the same so in all these
cases were not getting different labels
under this under you know after
smoothing
we're getting the same label for for the
for the original point and it's
perturbation so again we need to think
about what's the worst case kind of
decision we could make to make this
smooth classifier you know make mistakes
about these points
and it's not too hard to show that the
worst case you can do as an adversary
I'll have to pick any classifier you
want is actually a linear boundary
between the two so the worst the best
thing the adversary can do if it wants
to sort of maximally fool the classifier
is to just put a linear Xin boundary
between the positive you know between
one example and the other one and this
follows actually from as follows from
some basic fact since is a suppose from
that you know that the Neyman Pearson
lemma in hypothesis testing is little
big here he pointed out that actually
the same exact fact was was was from a
paper from 98 for high dimensional
gaussians in that case so essentially
the exact same thing but the underlying
fact is the best an adversary can do to
the worst case analysis maybe we have to
sort of analyze is the case of a linear
separator between X and X plus Delta and
a nice thing about that is that when you
apply Gaussian smoothing to a linear
separator it stays linear so all we have
to do is analyze the linear case to
figure out actually a worse case bound
on what any underlying classifier can do
and the nice thing about linear case of
course is that you know it's very simple
to compute things like the distance from
this point to a hyperplane that
separates the points and in fact this is
exactly what we do for and there's a
little bit informally stated but
essentially we can compute the Lt
distance between this and an incision
boundary and this sort of shows this
this is the actual radius where P is the
probability of this of this color blue
color here under this measure and when
you do that you basically implied any
perturbation with l 2-norm less than
this radius here because fo we had
before can't change the class label and
that's the that's the proof that that's
really all there is doing yeah so if you
try to move away from Gaussian
great question parametric inequality for
long - um so I don't know and so so so
we've thought a lot about non Gaussian
distributions Smit measures for like
hopefully getting guarantees for other
norms and cannot manage to get it to
work and other peas and including some
so Jeremy and and Alon as well as Jerry
have hypothesizing that it's actually
impossible to get anything other than l2
bounds with this exact approach without
more assumptions on the on the
classifier but available talk with that
offline because that's best that's a
pretty it's a pretty involved story
there yeah oh yeah so I'm almost out of
time okay let me just then show couple
things first of all caveats to the fine
print we're giving guarantees only for
the smooth classifier not the underlying
classifier no problem with that
everyone's okay with that um III I list
the the easy caveat first big caveat we
cannot compute the probability P all
right this is the integral of a knurled
for a neural network because the
integral of a I mean it's this is a
convolution of a Gaussian with the
prediction of a neural network you can't
do that tractable in high dimensions so
in fact need to resort to Monte Carlo
estimates to both form P to boast s but
not not actually get it to get a really
a lower bound on P and just certify the
prediction to get the radius which you
can certify it and we have Monte Carlo
and paper we have Monte color procedure
both of those and they hold high
probability now and again to be clear
this is a high probability over the
internal randomness is not like
something the adversary could fool
unless the adversary knows the random
see doing things like this right so
sending up something comes to graphic
randomness you can get this in bounce
with high probability the last thing
I'll say is that just to highlight
things we are certifying this boundless
aidid is tiny compared to the noise
we're injecting so noise we inject is
Gaussian random noise with with variance
Sigma squared which scales like Sigma
times D to the one-half right whereas
the breeze we're scaling mermaids were
certifying scales like just Sigma are
variance sorry our sanity be Asian so
when you see those these pictures here
like this you don't know that we are not
we are not certifying after total noise
like this
we are certifying that imperceptible
adversarial noise still by classifying
examples like this so there are still
this root the difference and how much
noise you have to add versus the radius
you can actually certify just just I
want to make that clear because these
pictures sometimes imply that we're
really robust when we're not nearly that
robust alright let me just have the two
results now and then I'll and I'll end
result number one this works better at
certifying radio you know larger radii
essentially then existing approaches
based upon the dual relaxations it
doesn't quite so if you use this same
architecture as these past approaches so
these these ones here are three
different runs of Eric's past work if
you run our method with the same
architecture this many men with a
marketer you get this line here so this
is showing the certified accuracy you
can obtain at what radius so of course
has your radius gets bigger you have
less certified accuracy you can bear it
can verify it almost dominates all of
these but the really nice thing here is
you because it's a much more scalable
approach just demands you know random
sampling not some weird LP constructed
on the actual network you can scale to
much bigger architectures and the
national dominate performance of past
methods that's pretty consistent without
too much tuning the real benefit of
course though is that we can scale the
things like image maps so for image that
we can also get guarantees really and
this bit this this and to be clear the
approach is that you know we're doing
the since concept before I was the only
known defense provable defense that
works at image net scale and so I've
something I'll skip to this this one
here you know for example for fur we can
certify a smooth classifier that has top
one for the accuracy of 37 percent under
any perturbation with l 2-norm less than
1 or here 1 is in normalized pixels so
again that's not very big radius a
perturbation and that's this point sort
of right here but this is the first time
that this is sort of much better than
the existing formal bounce which
essentially are vacuous on image net and
it's also clarified like the reason why
as you add more noise here your accuracy
goes down so you know this is adding a
little bit of noise then the naive
accuracy is this so you know even with
no perturbation
etc
with when you add noise you can certify
a bigger radius but your accuracy goes
down because when you add noise things
like this class which is a starfish
become completely washed out and so
there is a fun little trade-off between
noise and mm okay so that's all I think
I've mentally asked answered most of the
questions in the in the thing I alluded
some of these these strange things I
think we're gonna have to have bounds
that depends on both the probability and
the property the net worth to do much
better than this and all the code we
have and mauls experiments are available
Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so statement that shallower and wider
networks for more of us that was only in
terms of the other bounds I was talking
about here for for this smoothing
approach there is no correlation between
the the shallows of the network and
being better in fact all really what all
that really ends up happening is the
better you are at classifying random
noise the better your orbit sorry images
with random noise to be claimed better
you'll do and so typically the more
power you have your network the better
you are at that task and so the better
you do so the statement about shallow
networks does not apply to the
randomized smoothing case just to the
other balance I think it's an artifact
of the belt
IIIi don't think that you can really
extend the analysis to like the the
limit case of Gaussian processes here
because it's a different activation all
these things are very different and I
think the balance we get would be back
us on that case no matter what because
you would always have some looseness no
matter what so I I don't see the
connection with with sort of GPS in the
infinite limit though there might be
something interesting there too I think
it's better just analyze GPS GPS I think
the the people who did the work so this
are my amazing students and yeah so I
want to talk about the missile
perturbations but somehow